WON'T THROW IT AWAY FOR THE SAKE
OF MORE IMMIGRATION.
LAWMAKERS IN CALIFORNIA HAVEN'T
GOTTEN AROUND TO FIXING THE
STATES IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE OR
VANISHING MIDDLE CLASS BUT THEY
ARE AT THE FOREFRONT OF ANOTHER
FIGHT REWRITING GRAMMAR.
LAST WEEK THE CHAIR OF THE STATE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCED THAT ONLY GENERAL
NEUTRAL PRONOUNS WILL BE
PERMITTED ON HER OR RATHER THEIR
COMMITTEE.
>> SO THAT WE ARE USING WHAT MY
GRAMMAR TEACHER WOULD'VE HAD A
HEART ATTACK OVER, WE ARE USING
THE PHRASE "THEY."
MY GRAMMAR TEACHER IS LONG GONE
AND I WON'T BE HEARING FROM HER.
FROM THEM!
EXACTLY.
FROM THEY!
>> Tucker: JASON NICHOLS IS A
FREQUENT GUEST ON THIS SHOW,
THEY WILL JOIN US NOW.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I'M REALLY STRUCK, THIS IS A
FUNCTION OF HUMAN NATURE BUT THE
LEFT IS SUSCEPTIBLE TO IT.
ANY DUMB TREND THAT COMES ALONG
IS ACCEPTED IMMEDIATELY AND
MINDLESSLY BY PEOPLE WHO SHOULD
KNOW BETTER.
>> LIKE MAGA HATS?
>> Tucker: THEY ARE CALLING
FOR THE ELECTION OF A SPECIFIC
PERSON.
ALL THE DUMB PEOPLE DECIDED
PRONOUNS WERE BAD AND WE DECIDED
TO GO ALONG WITH IT.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY ARE SAYING
PRONOUNS ARE BAD.
THEY ARE SAYING YOU SHOULD BE
REFERRED TO THE WAY YOU CHOOSE
TO BE REFERRED TO.
SOMEONE WHO WAS A MAN WHO
IDENTIFIES AS A MAN, WE CAN CALL
THAT PERSON KEY.
SOMEONE WHO IDENTIFIES AS A
WOMAN, THAT PERSON CAN BE SHE.
A PERSON WHO IS GENDER NONBINARY
CAN BE THEY OR SHIM OR WHATEVER
PRONOUN THEY CHOOSE.
THIS BILL AND I CALL PEOPLE
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO BE CALLED.
I THINK THAT'S YOUR RIGHT.
OUT OF RESPECT I GO ALONG WITH
IT, THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING.
THEY ARE SAYING YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO USE GENDER PRONOUNS.
THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT.
>> I FIND THAT PROBLEMATIC.
I BELIEVE PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE WHAT THEY
WANT TO BE CALLED.
>> Tucker: THERE'S A PROBLEM
HERE, THIS IS A CALIFORNIA.
MORE THAN 10 MILLION PEOPLE
SPEAK SPANISH AT HOME, SPANISH
IS A GENDERED LANGUAGE.
THAT MEANS IT IS STRUCTURALLY
TRANSPHOBIC.
WILL THEY ALLOW SPANISH TO BE
SPOKEN, A GENDERED LANGUAGE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM?
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES, THERE IS LATINO
LATINA, AND LATIN X.
>> Tucker: THAT'S ENGLISH,
THAT'S HOW ENGLISH SPEAKERS
DESCRIBE IT BUT THERE'S NO
EFFORT TO IMPOSE THESE LUDICROUS
RULES ON SPANISH.
WHY NOT CALL CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA ASKED?
IF WE ARE MEANING CONSISTENT.
IF >> CALIFORNIA CAN'T CHOOSE.
>> Tucker: THEY'RE NOT LEADING
US CHOOSE.
IF YOU SAID I WOULD REALLY LIKE
YOU TO CALL ME THIS OUT OF
POLITENESS AND DECENCY WHICH I
SINCERELY BELIEVE IN, I WILL.
THEY ARE FORCING PEOPLE TO SAY
SOMETHING STUPID -- SHOULDN'T
THAT BE THE POINT WHERE THE REST
OF US SAY I'M NOT PLAYING ALONG?
>> YOUR CALLING IT STUPID.
I DON'T THINK IT'S STUPID TO
SAY -- THERE ARE PEOPLE MANY
YEARS AGO WHO SAID HIS NAME WAS
CASH'S CLAY, WE AREN'T GOING TO
CALL HIM MUHAMMAD ALI, THAT'S
STUPID.
UP TO ME, WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
BE CALLED WHATEVER YOU CHOOSE.
>> Tucker: I'M FOR CALLING HIM
MUHAMMAD ALI, BECAUSE HE WANTS
TO BE CALLED THAT.
NO PROBLEM.
THIS IS A COMMAND THAT REQUIRES
PEOPLE TO REFER TO PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NOT ASKED TO BE CALLED THIS
BY A PLURAL PRONOUN WHEN IT'S A
SINGULAR PERSON.
IT'S GRAMMATICALLY INCORRECT,
AWKWARD, IT'S DUMB, IT DOESN'T
SERVE THE INTEREST OF ANYBODY
AND IT APPLIES TO ALL OF US.
>> LANGUAGES LIVING AND
BREATHING IT CHANGES, IT SHIFTS.
IF YOU LISTEN TO HOW PEOPLE TALK
IN THE 1920s, THEY DON'T
TALK -- THEY DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH
THE SAME WAY THEY SPEAK ENGLISH
TODAY.
>> Tucker: ISN'T THAT AN
ORGANIC PROCESS?
IS NOT BECAUSE A TERRIFIED
BUREAUCRAT DECREES THAT YOU MUST
SAY THIS.
>> WE ARE IN AGREEMENT ABOUT
DECREEING THAT YOU HAVE TO SPEAK
ONE WAY OR USE A PARTICULAR
PRONOUN FOR EVERYONE.
I DON'T LIKE MANDATING THAT ALL.
>> Tucker: VERY QUICKLY ASSESS
THE RESPONSE.
WE BOTH AGREE WITH THIS.
WHY DON'T BOTH OF US NEXT TIME
WE HEAR IT SAY NO, I'M NOT
PLAYING ALONG WITH YOUR FANTASY,
LEAVE ME ALONE.
ARE YOU AFRAID TO DO THAT?
>> IF I WERE THERE I WOULD SAY I
WILL PREFER KEY.
I WILL CALL SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO
BE CALLED SAY OR WHATEVER
PRONOUN YOU CHOOSE.
>> Tucker: SHIR?
>> THAT'S ANOTHER ONE, NOT QUITE
AS POPULAR.
>> Tucker: I JUST DON'T THINK